From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Where are we running?
You want to, is that bag not in the way?
It's not, but it is better to keep it down.
Okay.
Look, we are rolling.
This is Emily Crosby with the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill.
And this morning's oral history is part of the Civil Rights History Project,
which is sponsored by the Smithsonian Institution National Museum of African American History and Culture,
and the American Folklife Center in the Library of Congress.
Today is June 27, 2013, and we're in Silver Spring, Maryland with Mr. Luis Supata at his home.
And with me is John Bishop.
Thanks so much for joining us this morning.
Thank you.
Whether it's a great thing to do.
Can you start by telling me about your family and where you grew up?
Well, I grew up in Orange County, California, at the home of the crew, not at the home of the John Bird Society.
Sorry.
I was moving ahead too far.
The John Bird Society is right when you can get.
My folks were, I guess, liberal Democrats, you probably say.
And I grew up until I left out when I was really young, and had no idea about politics.
So all that came much later in my, or later in my life, not much later.
What kind of work did your parents do?
My father was an engineer.
He always had trouble because it's a mechanical engineer.
And, you know, my father had let me know, and my mother's anglo, and so he had some trouble with that in jobs and stuff like that.
My mother owned a yarn shop when on and off and taught knitting and things like that,
so not someone crocheting and crew work.
And I remember about growing up over some of the things that shaped your life.
Oh.
Goodness.
Getting beat up as a kid, coming home from school, you know, for, and there wasn't a large Latino population in the community.
And, and I remembered having lots of problems, and, yeah, that's the, mm-hmm.
Lots of problems, and until I learned to fight back, and, and eventually, I just, I went off and actually left home for a young, came back, left home for a young.
You know, there was, finding about the ladies and stuff like that, and, you know, what young men do.
Was, how did your family deal with racial cultural identity in that context?
They didn't address it at all.
It was not talked about, it was not addressed, it was not anything.
So you were sort of on your own to figure that out.
And, um, I remember my brother was dating somebody, and her mother said, no, you can't.
And, uh, because, to the daughter, and nobody ever talked about it, it just was accepted, that's the sort of thing that happened.
So, I'm sorry, he couldn't date.
Oh, the mother of his person.
Yeah, the young lady's mother said, okay, not your mother.
I will not have that.
And, she said, I'm sorry, but I can't do it.
And, that's, you know, that was standard back then.
We're talking about in the 50s.
Yeah.
And so, and he was older than I was.
Yeah. Did you and your brother talk about it at all?
Or was it all just flu?
No, no, we didn't talk about it.
Yeah.
He had his problems, and he still does, and I, you know, I just leave it be.
So, you say you left home fairly young.
What did you do when you left home?
Well, I started working.
I think I was about 10, 9 or 10.
And I'd work in people's gardens and make money, and I had a paper route, and then I'd work on boats and scrape boats, because I could swim.
I'd dive down, you go into boat, and you scrape the seaweed off and stuff.
And then some of my friends and I would, there were tour boats that would go out from Newport Beach, and they would throw quarters, and we'd dive down and get quarters, and that sort of thing.
Tell I burst my ear drums, too, when I was a kid.
And from there, I became a dishwasher and a bus boy, and then I learned to be a short-order cook, and actually being a short-order cook is something, and eventually a chef.
I worked all over the country, and if I was traveling, somebody needed somebody, and you can always find job as a short-order cook.
And if you know how to do it, you can eat a whole day's worth of food in an eight-hour shift, and, you know, something don't pay you that much, you don't still don't have a food bill.
It sounds like you've picked up quite a few handy skills over the years.
Yeah, and I guess working, my mother taught me to knit, when I was, I think I didn't knit.
I don't know how old I was, my first slippers. I had to knit, much slippers, knit them.
And I become a craftsman, that's not on my biography for some reason, but a lot of the stuff you see around here, I made myself, I do Native American craft work and other craft work.
I was making sandals and selling them, can't make a living as a crafts person, so.
But, you know, my hands are good enough, so I was a carpenter and a cabinet maker over the years, and done things with my hands.
How did you get involved in movement work?
Well, I really guess it happened, I went to San Jose State College, and that's probably where I really learned about politics.
I was liberal, I remember being some kid in school, called me a communist in elementary school or high school, named this junior high, in Newport Beach, and I didn't even know what a communist meant.
But I started to understand politics and get involved in politics.
I went to school first as a physics major, what that was about.
But I didn't fit it in very well with the physics majors, but I became at San Jose, and that was during all the things were happening at Berkeley.
And I became politicized and got more politicized, it was involved in, you know, invasion of the Dominican Republic and all those things.
And then I went to work with farm workers, and, um, get organized, you know, working the fields.
So did you, when you went to San Jose State, was that part of a, you know, was that a regular sort of trajectory or out of graduate high school, go right into college?
Well, I wasn't, I mean, there was some spaces because I was working.
But yes, my, the objective was I'd get a degree in physics, and I, I'd become a normal person, and that never happened.
And being an engineer, or something.
No person never did happen, you know, that couldn't happen.
Or, you know, some sort of scientist. I think I wanted to be an astronaut or something at one point in life.
And, but that, you know, I can tell all sorts of stories, but the physics majors, I couldn't even talk to them.
They just, they lived in a whole different world. I was worried about social issues, and they didn't know what a social issue was.
You didn't think about changing your major, you just went for the...
I actually, of course, dropped out. I was with farm workers and the story behind that is, they had started the Mississippi Freedom Labor Union, and, and somebody at, it may have been League Bankhead, who was the head of Mississippi Freedom Labor Union under Kofo.
I don't know who contacted Chavez, but Chavez said, meeting anybody want to go to Mississippi.
And I said, what the heck, a campaign?
Yeah, we were here because we were getting beaten up all the time by the guy. I didn't know they were going to shoot at us in Mississippi. Damn.
But anyway, I stuck up my hand. Next thing I know I was in Mississippi.
Well, and...
So I didn't, I dropped out of college.
Okay.
And it wasn't until, oh, probably the 80s or the 90s, I went back and eventually got it, and I didn't go back in physics.
I got it to Green English.
Better, sure.
Because, then more writing than I'd done anything else.
So, I'd like to ask a little bit more about how you got involved with the farm workers, but just to clarify,
were you in school until you went to Mississippi, were you working at with the farm workers?
Yeah, I was pretty much in school.
Yeah, I was pretty much in school, although I dropped the number of credits I was taking, so I could do more with farm workers.
But I think I was still officially registered.
Yeah.
And then I just left.
I said, you know, this isn't makes sense. This isn't what I want to do with my life.
So how did you connect with the farm workers and become an organist?
Well, they were all around, San Jose.
And so they were organizing in the fields outside in San Jose.
I mean, they were everywhere.
And, and a lot of Luis Valdés, I went to school, you know, he is, La Bumba.
And he became a well-known playwright, but I was already into English more than anything else.
And I, Luis Valdés and a lot of other Latinos were involved in all sorts of politics.
And how I got into it, I mean, it's just was like the Civil Rights Movement.
It was in the air.
I mean, you know, there was no major struggle like there was in the South,
but in terms of African Civil Rights, African-American Civil Rights in San Jose,
because San Jose at that time had the largest Latino population north of the border.
It was larger than it was in LA.
So, you know, it's just normal.
So did was, did, did becoming, did working with the farm workers,
did that then give you a space to be Latino in a different way after sort of it,
not being addressed in your family?
It's interesting.
I mean, I didn't thought about that.
Probably I was moving into that.
And, interestingly enough, of course, there wasn't any space to do that in Mississippi.
And it just, I'm not to jump through history.
It was after I came out, of course, one of the things that was happening in the Afro-American movement
is they were looking to the dyspora and back to Africa.
And I started to focus on, after Mississippi, not so much the Latino,
but the Native American issues, because we are most Native people.
The brown comes, doesn't come from the few Africans.
And there were a lot of Africans that were brought to Mexico and other areas,
and especially Cuba and places, but most of it comes from Native people.
Although it's colonized enough that they don't focus on that,
but usually I am, in fact, supposed to be a letter published in the post,
Russian post, I just wrote about that and folks not paying attention to it.
That it's a Native American issue.
Yeah.
The...
Whoops.
Am I supposed to repeat anything?
I don't know what I said.
I saw a periodically too close the file.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, understood.
So, what kind of...
Tell me about organizing with the farm workers.
Well, I was a kid.
And I was a kid when I went to Mississippi in terms of experience.
I became a fairly good organizer, I think.
I'm now considered a pretty good organizer.
But we were just...
We told Gwauten the Field and go join the workers,
and then convince them, because there'd be people yelling and screaming saying,
you know, come on strike, join us, Welga, et cetera.
And so I was supposed to join in the fields and then convince people who were working around me
to go join and get a whole bunch and we'd walk out on strike.
And usually it was one or two or three of us who were doing that.
The people who had been working for a long time doing it were known by the cops
and known...
And a lot of times the cops weren't there, but the thugs that went plantations,
they were farms.
The farms, the thugs knew who were the organizers,
and they wouldn't let them under the field.
But since they needed hands, you could go in and say,
I'm just in Address and Raggedy clothes.
And I'd go in and they let me in there, then the main idea was we'd take people out.
We'd leave people out on strike, because we were trying to do this strike.
There were other things happening.
There was a grape strike, of course, which was PR.
I mean, that was all about getting to the median, making speeches.
But I was just as young kid.
I didn't know what I was doing.
So you...
So the grape strikes going on, but is this a different strike?
There was also...
I usually worked on the strawberry strike.
I mean, they were working for higher wages.
I even worked one time on Sparigas boys, and Sparigas hard to pick.
Each little thing with this little hook and I...
God.
Even my back is a lot older now, but...
But no, it was getting higher wages for almost all of the things.
But what made the media and what they were asking people all around the country
to boycott California grapes unless they had a unionized sticker on it.
But I don't think...
I never worked in a grape field.
I never were picking grapes.
And so when...
At this meeting, when they were looking for somebody to go to Mississippi,
did you have a picture of Mississippi in your head?
And the slightest idea when I was volunteering for young kid who thinks,
oh, this...
That's good.
I knew about, you know, black struggles, etc.
I don't know what he was doing.
No, I went down there and...
It was more community organizing and I got into that.
And...
I have done lots of thinking over the years about how isolated it was that time
for people in the rural areas all across the South.
TV, if you had it, the biggest news was who won the bass fishing contest.
It was almost no national news.
There were no national papers.
You get these local papers that just talked...
Again, about the bass fishing contestor, who married who?
And you had no sense of...
Geopolitical, certainly not other countries.
Nothing was mentioned about other countries.
And so you really didn't focus on national pictures.
It was only until I went back...
I forgot what I was...
Maybe on Mike Espice campaign.
And I saw cable TV and rise up people at cable TV in their homes.
And they were watching New York stations.
And seeing stuff that had never...
Nobody would ever saw when I was there in terms of national news.
We got more via SNCC channels of things happening in Africa and New York than we certainly did.
To the news media.
It was nothing on.
Yeah.
So no idea about Mississippi.
Did you have much sense of SNCC before you got to Mississippi?
No, I was a little about SNCC because they were in San Jose making speeches and stuff.
I mean, I knew enough, I think to understand that SCLC was the...
The middle of the road or the less militant.
And by then I was getting pretty militant.
And so I understood that this wasn't a fairly militant.
But it wasn't until I got immersed in that.
And I began to understand the real differences.
And what was...
I don't even know if I understood what Kofo was back then.
It was, okay, they're starting a union.
And I'm just going to have an help.
And that will help all people's, etc.
And yeah, I was naive.
I mean, you know, and people like to look back and say how they were...
Had great insight.
I didn't have great insight.
I was working and organizing, getting people to try and join the strike
and doing that sort of thing and all sorts of discussions about that.
We did a lot of voter registration.
I probably spent as much of more time doing voter registration, things like that.
Getting head start programs going and all the things.
Everybody did everything.
Mm-hmm.
Do you remember how you came into Mississippi?
Like who you met first?
Well, I think I met Lee Bankhead first, because they were waiting for me.
And I had a map.
And I brought down a car loaded with clothes.
And it was a car that was a gift to Snick or Kofo.
I don't know who it was a gift to.
And it was loaded with clothes for people and some other stuff.
And I think I was alone.
I don't remember.
Over the years, because I actually went north a number of times
or to California and did fundraising.
Over the years, I think I brought three cars down, including one Hearst,
which we had to tell people it was an ambulance because nobody would ride it.
I was going to say that I'm a little ominous going into Mississippi with the Hearst.
People didn't, because it had some of the stuff stripped off and it was black.
But then we tell them it was an ambulance because people would say,
there's big vehicles.
Nobody needed seats.
You just packed bodies in.
I had all sorts of drivers license.
I had a Mississippi driver's license.
California driver's license.
Some places, when I was in New York, I think I got a New York driver's license.
You can have multiple drivers license back then.
Now it's all computerized.
But I had, you know, so I was always one of the drivers.
And there's some funny stories about driving in the north.
But that's okay.
And so, you know, we had to tell them it was an ambulance and everybody thought it was okay.
They could ride in it.
Is that going to interrupt?
Let me show you a set of...
It's hard to be a movie star.
You're just a blur, by the way.
You're all blur.
It's a small thing in the end.
Okay, wait a minute.
I can see the smiles.
I can see that.
But...
Okay, we're back.
A few minutes ago, you mentioned that by this time you're becoming militant.
Oh, I probably was...
Basically, I probably was militant when I was in elementary school and didn't know it.
What did that mean to you then?
I believed in fighting back, I guess, in struggling back.
Instead of just taking it and laying down, that you want to change the system if the system wasn't right.
And I don't know where I got that.
Certainly none of my folks weren't doing that.
None of the friends I had when I were younger, none of them were political.
In college, I met people who were doing that.
And I was very involved with them.
But, you know, it was just...
I guess it's in my instinct.
You know, it's just something about it.
You have to fight back.
Yeah.
So, when you got to Mississippi, you described driving in.
Do you remember how you were introduced to what SNCC and COFO were doing?
No.
I think there's...
And it's part of a lot of cultures.
There's not a lot of talking and explaining.
SNCC people tended to do more of it.
But they expected, I think, a seasoned union worker who knew how to organize.
And I knew a little bit how to organize and I figured it out on the run.
But over my life, I've learned a lot of times people don't explain stuff.
I was...
I forgot to put down iron workers.
I had no idea.
I was a union iron worker for a while.
And that means climbing tall buildings and putting steel together.
Nobody really tells you how to do it.
You go out there and you're supposed to watch and figure it out.
And the same thing I guess was true for cooking.
Or being a short-order cook is nobody gigging or going to class.
They didn't have classes for that.
And you just figure it out.
And I would figure out how to convince people that they ought to join the union
and work to get higher wages.
And you tell them something and that didn't work and try and tell them something else.
And I learned pretty quickly it had to be usually for their personal benefit.
For me, of course, it was about we need to change the system.
But if I talked about changing the system, people get glassy-eyed.
They just wanted to have more money on the table because they couldn't feed their kids.
Right.
So you put things in terms of what helped them personally and how it was going to help their family,
their brothers and sisters who also were chopping cotton or picking cotton.
And that's how you did it.
I guess I figured it out pretty well.
People thought I was a pretty good organizer.
And I've gone on to do a lot of organizing and giving classes and organizing since then.
Who are some of the people that you worked most closely with in Mississippi?
It was mostly ministers.
Lee Bancad was the head of Mississippi Freedom Labor Union.
I guess on the board was Fannie Lou Hamer and Miss Ruffin and Reverend Johnson.
And I'm running out of names.
I can see lots of faces, but I'm running out of names.
There's another woman.
As you notice, most of those are women.
If they weren't women, they were usually ministers.
Because the men had to work generally.
But the movement, I'd say, was carried on the back of really strong women and ministers who were willing to stand up.
And that was a great deal.
I expect because ministers couldn't get fired by the white establishment.
Everybody else basically worked for Mr. Charlie.
And so if you wanted to, and people would get fired for trying to register to vote or for organizing.
And so, those are the people who made the decisions.
And you probably know about, enough about SNCC,
that it is a bottom up.
I mean, it's grassroots organization.
And it's not like, and I don't want to disparage any of the other civil rights organizations that were top down.
And some of those leaders have now very famous and have statues and stuff like that.
And they're good people, but it's a very top down decision-making process.
SNCC was always a grassroots bottom up.
And we got paid, as I recall, it was $20 a week out of which they took taxes and all that.
So it was either $17 and change or $18 and change.
Not a whole lot of money.
But the reason they paid you that, and they were clear about it,
is if you couldn't live off the community, if people who were dirt-forward and didn't have anything,
weren't willing to share their food and their enlarging, then you shouldn't be there.
Either the community thought you were worthwhile or get you butt out.
You were telling us earlier about some of the families that you lived with in Mississippi?
Oh, you were talking about, well, I stayed with them for a while.
I lived with another, I wasn't mostly out of Cleveland.
And so let me tell you about the shack we had in Cleveland.
It was behind somebody's house and we could take a shower in there.
It had a commode in a sink behind a curtain.
And that was the SNCC office in the Mississippi Freedom Labor Union office and the COFO office.
And it was one room when I went back years later to work on Mike S.B.'s campaign.
I drove by it and saw it.
It's not half as big as this room is.
I mean, it was this little teeny thing.
And we would, we stacked center blocks up around the bottom and we'd sleep on the floor.
Because occasionally people come by and shoot at night and they shoot through it.
And so you use the blocks as protection?
Yeah, we just sleep there and you know, you know, happened often enough you didn't even hardly wake up.
Because they wouldn't come in. They just drive by shoot.
But no, the family you were talking about.
That's just one of many hundreds of stories.
And I mentioned that to you earlier.
And some, I guess he volunteered to have somebody come and do voter registration.
He's black and probably about six foot ten, maybe taller.
And he had it on plantation and he had workers on it.
And he and his kids worked it too. They worked the fields.
They worked their butt off.
And I remember when I was driven out there, somebody from SNCC drove me out.
And it was pitch black and I said, dogs were barking and this person comes out.
I'm not that small. I was, you know, about six foot.
I think I'm five, eleven and a half.
And he gets me out of the arms and I start to go up and up and up until I'm face with somebody.
I go, okay, what am I doing here?
Nice guy, wonderful family. Fed me more food and I keep saying, you're done eating?
What's wrong, boy?
They packed in so much food breakfast, which was their big meal.
Look like Thanksgiving dinners every morning with pancakes and waffles and sausage and biscuits
and hamburgers and rice and ham.
And of course, they grew up and they had, you know, farm and had all those animals.
But they just packed some food in and...
Yes. But he'd take me every day.
Every morning, he went out out.
He was there and actually went out in the fields before sun up.
And then he'd come back a little after day break and take me to groups of houses and leave me there
and I was trying to get these people to register to vote.
Which was a standard thing to do.
Not quite that way. I'd never been on a black plantation before.
And he was well respected and I'd probably somewhat feared, especially in the white community,
yet shot gun and a rifle in the back of his pickup truck.
And nobody messed with him.
But yeah, that's just one of the, you know, hundreds of stories.
We spent years in someplace and doing organizing and you know, whatever.
I know it's hard to always remember, but do you remember where he was?
Like which county or town?
I believe it was Washington. It was maybe a sunflower.
Yeah.
No, I'm guessing sunflower.
And it'd be interesting to research it.
I've wondered about that. He probably was well known.
Yeah, I'd make a nice history, but I moved on after that and I saw him at meetings occasionally.
But he had a plantation to run and he worked hard.
I mean, he took time out to get people registered and he thought that was critical to get people registered.
And that was still during the time where you could go down. They turned your way.
The voting rights act hadn't been signed at that time.
And even after it was signed, that was, it took a long time to get implemented.
So if you were in Cleveland, you must have spent time with Amzy Moore.
Oh, sure.
Can you tell us what he was like?
Oh.
All right, goodness.
Very quietly strong. I'm trying to remember.
Some reason he was at a lot of meetings.
He usually didn't speak in churches that I can't remember.
Our big thing was to get music scores, singing freedom songs and getting firebrand speakers.
But I don't remember him speaking.
He did a lot of strategizing.
But I don't remember him. I was much closer to say, Fannie Mouhamer was a wonder of Miss Ruffin and people like that.
Can you tell us about both of them?
I remember Fannie Lou would get so mad she and she chewed tobacco and she gets so mad she's spitting and spitting and spitting again.
Everyone paid attention to her. Everyone listened to what she said.
She probably was as much the backbone of what happened in that part of the Delta is anybody.
Her henchman was Fannie Lou was a Miss Ruffin and I have no idea what Miss Ruffin's first name is or if I ever did know.
Susie.
Susie. Oh, really good.
Great lady. Between the two of them, the young guys had come in from SNCC and they always deferred.
I mean, if there was an argument about or a disagreement, I might say, about how to handle, you know, whether we would work in this particular town or that particular town.
Nobody ever, I mean, she'd want all the arguments between the two of them.
So how would they do it? Would they just say what they thought?
They'd say, no, that won't work. And you don't know what you're talking about.
And they just bullied their way into it. Yeah, they tough ladies, tough, tough ladies.
You said before we started filming that Ivan Ho Donaldson was a really good organizer?
He did not organize in the Delta while I was there that I knew of.
But in terms of tricks for organizing, you know, he'd come in and stuff.
He was probably in, had an instinct for being on a one-to-one or one-to-small group of people in terms of getting folks involved and doing stuff is credible.
I mean, there are people that stand out, Stokely, Carmichael, and Kwame Torreina.
How did, how did he stand out? He was good. He certainly was a good organizer.
He certainly was fearless. But I think that people really, some reason you, I, and I don't know maybe is what Ivan Ho looked like.
He looked like just somebody from the field. I mean, he really did. If you looked at him, you wouldn't think he was anybody but another field hand.
And he knew how to talk and act in a way that it convinced people. And then there were people like Bob Moses, who probably to me was the intellectual,
who lead and snick. And I mean, he had the book learning, he had the, you know, of course the intelligence and the insight.
And in terms of pan-Africanism and linking that, he probably eyesight as the person who, he's thinking formulated it.
Yeah. So do you remember, so you're doing voter registration work and you're working with the Mississippi Farm Labor Union.
Do you remember the discussions in Mississippi about whether or not to put on the summer project?
That happened. The summer project came right after I got there. It came about four or five months. And they were just coming as all I knew.
So that was already in the works. It was in the works. And I was just, you know, I was now I joined in. I mean, I'm a seasoned political hack or whatever you call it.
Then I would attend meetings, but I, I was naive little kid. I mean, I wasn't a little kid, but I was, you know, I was certainly, I didn't participate.
Oh, wait, I might get into a discussion about whether we should go to this thing or have a rally at this church.
But in terms of the grand strategy, that was done over my head. And I probably, well, it was a good thing because I didn't know enough to understand what was going on.
And a lot of decisions were made. And by the way, I, I told people since then, I was telling people at the 50th anniversary reunion of SNCC that the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party and the challenge
probably is the reason that we have a solid Republican Salad somehow. Because once and the civil, you know, once we got the Voting Rights Act and they realized that black folks were going to vote and the Democratic Party was going to probably be majority black all over the South. People fled the Republican Party. And back then, no Republican could win anything in the South.
And so did we foresee that? I don't know that anybody at any time said, well, what the result of this is going to be is the Republican South. And that's what we have now. And that's, of course, a key political factor in a lot of the things that I think are wrong with this country.
So, you know, unintended consequences. Do you have a sense of how did the, do you remember whether or how the summer project changed the work you were doing on a day-to-day basis?
We had a lot of volunteers who were green and didn't know what they were doing. They were willing to go out and do stuff because they didn't know how dangerous it was.
We had, I didn't work with that many of them, but a lot of, there were a lot of mass demonstrations. They could knock on a lot more doors and we did that.
And I guess I had a season enough to give them a lot of information. There was a lot of pushback about some of the more seasoned civil rights workers that these folks didn't know exactly what they were doing.
And maybe it wasn't worth the effort because they were taking up resources. They were very useful in helping us, every call getting some of the head start schools going because a lot of them were college students with, you know, education, et cetera.
I guess I was a college student of education, but I didn't think of it that way. What do you do with physics to create? You mean, right? I didn't finish it ever. But that's, you know, I was, you know, I could teach math and I did. I too didn't math sometimes.
Yeah. But they were really helpful in the head start schools and some of the other programs we had people would send clothes down and we had distribution programs. And they were going to working that stuff out in terms of going out and going to field and getting someone who was chopping cotton to, to agree to join the union.
It takes, being a community organizer takes getting empathy from the person you're organizing. And it's a one on one or one on a few people.
They didn't, they might have made it if they had lots of time, but they're only there for most of them for the summer.
Yeah.
I know at a certain point, Nick shifted from regular voter registration in the summer to registering people for the FTP.
Were you involved in that or any of the FTP organizing?
Oh, it was all one group. I mean, we didn't, that FTP weren't separate. And Lawrence Giot was always there and people like that.
Yeah. I think of it as that biggest shift.
We had to get them registered. Otherwise, that was always key is getting people registered to vote because if you didn't vote, being in it.
But a lot of our meetings focused on joining MFTP. And so there was a lot of emphasis on that and what that could do.
Where were you based that summer? Do you remember? Were you still in Cleveland?
Yeah, I was, I, I was pretty much always, that's where I most of my stuff stayed.
Yeah. I would go plus stay places. I went down to Delta Plines Plantation and hit out there while we were doing it.
And hit out as a word because they were looking for us. And we'd sleep in ditches and stuff.
So I have go places and maybe go work someplace for three days a week or even longer. But my stuff, which is considered a couple of pairs of jeans.
And I used to shave then and had a razor, I guess. That would stay in a toothbrush.
I don't know if I took my toothbrush. No, if I brushed my teeth. I'm a must've.
I know. And I must've brushed my teeth anyway. But I don't remember brushing my teeth. You never ever think about those things.
Routine. Routine. Those things that you do.
And I was, I guess I have to admit. One of the places I did a lot of organizing, especially young men and women, is I would go to the joints, drink beer and dance.
And most of the SNCC workers didn't do a lot of that. So you developed a special talent?
Yes. I drink a lot of beer. Colt 45. Yes, I drink a lot of beer.
And you know, but those places to organize, you can talk to people. Wherever you can meet people and talk to them.
Did you go to the precinct meetings or district caucuses or any of that going up to that?
I think I'd ever go to a district caucus meeting. I certainly went to precinct meetings.
And I certainly, yeah, I remember driving because I was one of the drivers. So I would, you know, in the, in the hearse.
Did we talk about that?
I would drive the vehicles. And so I'm, yeah, I went to, but I would drive.
I wasn't up front doing stuff. I was in the back urging people to participate and stuff like that.
I mean, I was not in that leadership and snicked and monison that leadership.
I mean, there was them that they were there to make the decisions. If it was going to be a Mississippi Democratic party, a Freedom Democratic party, then they had to take the leadership of it.
The whole idea of the Salilinski model, where you work yourself out of a job, you want people to lead and make the decisions.
So I never tried to do that.
Some people have talked about what it was like to kind of see that in action during the FTP meetings leading up to the, the state convention in Jackson.
And then, you know, if they were there in Atlantic City.
I didn't go to either Jackson or Atlanta. I know I didn't go to Atlantic City.
I would came up here for the challenge to Washington DC. I was drove a whole bunch of people up.
I didn't go to either. And I'm not sure why it's.
Again, maybe I had no reason to go except as a driver and they didn't need a driver.
I was neither. When you drove people to DC, was that to do lobbying and preparation?
No, it was a challenge. I guess you call it lobbying. We came up and we stayed at also's church, filled the basement.
And we'd go every day and the Congress building and to the Democratic Party headquarters and do basic lobbying.
And so was this, this was the congressional challenge in the Samer and this gray and stuff.
So how long were you up here for that? You know, I mean, just roughly, I'm not asking you know.
I'm guessing two weeks.
Yeah, okay. And so you were helping drive people around.
I would drive people. You like stories? My favorite story was, and I mean, I driven in the big city in California.
I driven in LA and San Francisco, you know, and Oakland and places like that.
But I was driving this car and going back to all souls from something we were at.
Maybe it was a rally on the mall, I don't remember.
And whoever heard of turning a six lane street into one way when it was two way the other time.
If DC has these streets and anybody who's in DC knows this.
And I turned on to this street and I knew how to get back to the church.
And I'm looking at all this traffic facing me.
And there's a cop sitting there.
And he looks at me and then he looks at the people in the car half of which was still wearing bandanas from working in the field.
Because these are mostly union people. So they were field workers and nobody told them to dress up.
They didn't bring their Sunday clothes. He looks at me. He looks at the people in the car. He looks at the Mississippi tags.
He looks at me and he looks at people in the car and looks at the Mississippi tags. And he just shakes his head.
And he holds up all this traffic. Makes a big deal out of me. He said, come on.
You know, you feel about this big. I'm saying, I'm driven in the city before but nobody has one way streets that were two way.
Yes, you know, and they make it one way going out because it's all about the suburbs.
So it's a two way street most of the day and it's one way going out in the afternoon, one way coming in in the morning.
I do not drive.
Did you have a chance to see Mrs. Hamer and Mrs. Gray and Mrs. Devine do their sort of speak to people or talk about the issues.
I mean, that was normal because they did it all the time.
Yeah, I mean, the same thing happened in DC. On one hand, as I said, I was politically more politically naive.
On one hand, I know this was a big deal and we were trying to upset the system and I knew all the politics of it.
But I didn't have a good geopolitical, I mean, I wasn't in strategy groups.
And so I don't think I really was focused on the import because it was my job to get people to come.
Many bodies as I couldn't say. I was out there saying all this great stuff I'm going to do this, how important it is.
And then once we're here logistically making sure people got fed, people showed up where we're supposed to be, what building it is,
give me a map so I can find it.
But I wasn't at that level of leadership. Now, in the union, I had more to say and what we're trying to do with the union.
But MFDP had its own leadership and they wanted local people and local officials to do it.
It wasn't, you know, it was, SNCC was very much about that. We were witnesses and facilitators. And that was what we're supposed to do.
And what about, you mentioned GeoTroll or in reference to FDP?
Well, he's a good friend and has been over the years. Sometimes I think he remembers his role as more, anyway.
He was key to it. He was certainly a powerful figure. And he certainly was key to developing the strategies.
And being from Mississippi, he had, you know, he played that card a lot when people would say who weren't from Mississippi, we think this, he'd say, well, you're not from here, you don't get to make that decision.
And I've heard him say that many, many times. He didn't take too well to people who disagreed with him.
I don't know if you were aware of this or involved in this at all, but I know that after the convention challenge, there was some differences between SNCC and FDP over endorsing Johnson, Humphrey and working for them. Can you speak to them?
No, I really, that was, again, I let decisions like that be made by other folks. I'm, I, I, to be honest, I know what I'd say now. And I don't know what I would have said then if my opinion had been asked.
But that wasn't my decision. And I shouldn't have, even if I had an opinion.
But, you know, so, so, so talk about you said in the union work that you had more say in shaping things. Can you talk about that?
Well, it's how we would, you know, and at one point that we even started, there was started a co-op that was union. And that wasn't Shaw, sorry, recall.
But it was the strategy of what do we do now? You know, can we really have a strike? Will people, will a plantation owners just get other people in from other areas? And we did have a number of small strikes.
Could we just leverage and demand for better wages? How many people could we get out to do certain things? And it was more day to day level about, because that was handled by a smaller group.
And, like I said, there were a few leaders who were local. And so we, but we, they, we had more input.
It seems like it was a real difficult context because mechanization had been, had already had such an impact on the delta and the number of laborers.
Yes, certainly, certainly for a lot of things. But when it came to chopping cotton and chopping cotton and explaining people don't know what to do, can you get the weeds out? Johnson grass is the biggest thing. And you take a hole and you chop all of the weeds with a hole.
I don't know what they ever found anything that will replace just back breaking labor. And picking cotton, although there are some mechanical devices picking cotton, especially if it's a smaller plantation, it doesn't pay to do any of that by hand.
So we did have some leverage. Some of the other things like corn and stuff like that, we didn't invite that battle. Yeah, you picked that automated corn pickers, etc.
So can you describe the decision to actually try the strike and what happened?
Well, we try some small strikes on, we strike individual plantations. And there were a couple of times we actually got better wages. And there were a couple of times more than a couple, more than about eight times.
And I couldn't remember the plantation owner's names if I had to, or maybe I don't know, maybe somewhere in the recesses. But it was always an ongoing decision about whether this was going to work.
Do we have enough people? We're enough folks signed up from that plantation. If you didn't have the majority, then it wasn't even worth it.
Would they bring others in and therefore people would just be without a job because there's nowhere else to go. Nobody else at higher you once they heard you were striking.
We had food banks set up on several occasions and we'd get people to send money. And that's one of the things I did when I was in the north is I'd raise money for food and clothes.
So could we sustain the people and for how long and who would take care of the kids, you know, and people had some really, really hard decision.
We got, we never had a large major coordinated strike across all of a large enough area of the delta to make any differences for the county, Oliver County.
But we did increase the wages for some people which then forced other plantain plantation owners. We learned, raised their wages to be competitive so people wouldn't jump to another plantation.
So we had what I would call a limited success. And we considered any, you know, 10 cents an hour, a large increase.
You know, I'm not sure about the timing of this and this might have been after I was trying to look at the dates, but this might have been after you left Mississippi. But at one point there's a strike where enough people are striking that people get evicted.
And they set up a tent city and take over the air base. Where you part of that.
But that was, where was that? That wasn't in Baltimore County.
It was Miss Blackwell. You need a Blackwell was involved. And so I know she was in Myersville, but I'm not sure, Sharky area, but I'm not sure that's where the strike was.
Yeah. And I heard about actually a lot of that happened and it was still happening when I came back when I was north one time.
Everything.
Some of them get mixed up in my head. I'm sorry. It's been a lot of years and I don't focus on this much.
I think that happened actually. It wasn't in, it wasn't in Baltimore County. Maybe I think it was in sunflower.
And it was set up by the time I got back, but they had a lot of internal problems.
And I never really got that involved. And then it was still ongoing when I left though.
Okay. When you would go north and raise money, would you set up those trips or would Snick set them up and then you'd just come in and sneak?
Snick would have a schedule for me. And I went to California a couple of times New York Boston, Washington DC.
And they had churches. They had placed for me to stay. They just needed my body there. And I tell them what was happening and tell them how much we needed and what we needed.
And then there was always some other folks from the local Snick offices. The local Snick offices in the north really did mostly support organizations.
And so they would take checks and they would collect the food and that sort of thing.
Yeah. So I've heard these stories about Snick meetings, you know, when the group would gather for what, you know, sort of as a staff.
Did you participate in those meetings? Do you have many?
We had some small ones. Of course, the Delta is in the in the west of Mississippi. Most of them were in Alabama.
I mean, that's where the big, you know, in Jackson. And then the thing in Jackson. I went to a few in Jackson.
But we didn't have many local. I didn't leave the area much. So you do.
Yeah, I went to Jackson occasionally. I was a decent ride to go to Jackson. Yeah. Yeah.
So there'd be local meetings and that's where I'd attend. But I didn't go.
Nor was I interested because I thought, you know, I was supposed to be working there.
So you'd stay close to the field when you really travel to Atlanta or different places?
That's what I thought. That's what my, my role was.
Now I'm older and different and I get involved in leadership decisions and stuff like that.
But even then, even now, if you, I'd work a lot of political campaigns and,
and there are, when you do a political campaign, I may, for quasi-infumé, I was the, his coordinator from Montgomery County.
And so Montgomery County decisions, you know, I was part of all those decisions.
Statewide, you know, I went to not that many of the meetings and because they didn't have that many statewide.
And then there was a core of people that made decisions and that's, that's a top-downs thing again.
But that's a lot of ways things happen. They made decisions that, that, and we got a newsletter that we tell us about.
What was that called?
Hmm. Was that a Mississippi newsletter?
No, it was a, it was a, it was a New York newsletter.
Was that the one for staff?
Yeah, and we get that.
And then of course we get phone calls and they tell us, and we go watch line, you know, you know, you're about to watch line, we go watch line.
And, and then, and the newsletter was always great because, was it Frank Chachorca?
It was a great, great, hard stuff. Yeah.
Really, I wonder what happened to him?
I think he passed not that long ago, like in the last four years maybe.
I remember, I never did. You know, I, I'm on a SNCC email list and I can't read it all. I'm sorry.
It's, you know, that there's got to be 30 emails a week and I, you know, I'm in a lot of email lists.
Yeah, but Lee Bank had, I heard, had passed, I heard that when I was at the reunion.
Okay. I believe that's correct.
I don't know much about him.
No, Lee is a woman. Oh, okay. I didn't know much about her.
She was, she was, she was, I guess, director of the Mississippi Freedom Library Union.
Okay. Do you, can you tell us about her?
Strong woman, very thoughtful, well organized, knew everybody, didn't do a lot of, in the field organizing herself, but she, you know, she was,
the person who, you know, all decisions went through her for the union.
Where was she from?
I believe Cleveland.
Yeah.
If it wasn't Cleveland, there was somewhere around there because that roots were in that area.
So from the Delta, for sure. Yeah.
So the, the, the, the, the SNCC staff meeting in Wavelin, Mississippi in November of 64 is one of these sort of infamous meetings.
Do you have any recollection of that?
Is that the kind of thing that you wouldn't go to?
I didn't go to.
You just stay in the field.
I probably read, read about it.
Yeah.
That doesn't even ring any bail of bells.
I mean, there was a lot of sort of discussion in the organization about the white volunteers who were staying on and, and a contingent had gone to Guinea through Harry Belafonte, and there was a lot of sort of flux within the organization about what do we do now in the aftermath of the challenge?
And form an invited people to write position papers.
And so there was this, you know, a lot of several days in Wavelin, Mississippi discussing all of these.
Yeah. I remember hearing that.
As I told you, there was some resentment about some of the volunteers who, who were not steeped in the SNCC tradition of, you know, its local control.
And they would come into meetings and sometimes want to make decisions and they'd stand up in meetings and say, well, we think this and that.
And I tell them afterwards, it's not our business.
You know, unless you're from here, you don't make a decision about here.
So yeah, there was some pushback.
And that was discussed in that meeting.
I heard about that.
I didn't get to send. Nobody was asked to leave that I know of.
I mean, so I don't know that any hard decisions that I knew of came out.
And to be honest, I haven't read a lot of the books.
I know Gene Wiley, who I've mentioned to you, who's a dear friend, and worked on a number of the history projects.
And you know, whenever I'm in California, I stay at her house and she's dead.
We don't have to show her those days much enough.
To be honest, I haven't read any of the stuff she's written, really.
I moved on.
Did you know her from SNCC?
I met her, I think, one time.
No, twice. She didn't come out in the field much.
I'm not going to other things she doesn't believe in using outhouses and every, no place I ever worked at anything but outhouses.
And she liked, you know, she was an office person.
She, again, tremendously organized, thoughtful, and analytical.
And she's like Moses, like Bob Moses.
So you said that there's tons and tons of stories.
Can you tell us some of your favorite ones?
Favorite ones.
I can talk about it in public.
Well, one time the Deacons of Defense and Justice came.
And I guess you know who it is, but they were a group from Louisiana and they decided they would have come across the border.
And we had, they energized a lot of people.
And of course, Nick was non-violent, so we know I couldn't, whatever.
But we had this deputy sheriff, deputy weeks, I think, was his name.
I don't know his first name.
Who used to beat folks all the time.
And he was just pretty open about it.
And he stuck his shotgun in my chest one time.
And he was not exactly a friendly guy.
Somebody apparently threw him all the time cocktail on his plant porch in this place in the country where he and his family stayed.
And nobody was hurt.
He changed around 100%.
Or 90% or 75%.
And he had a lot of people attitude to being a nasty son of a bitch.
Do you have an explanation for that?
He didn't want to see his kids burnt up.
So he figured that he had to do right if you aren't going to see that kind of retaliation?
I know if he could hold it right.
He had to pull back because people could fight back.
And as I said, you know, Nick was non-violent and officially I don't know anything about any of that.
To him.
You know, even though I was considered one of the drivers around there.
Oh, another good story.
I was the one, because you know, we get chased a lot down country roads.
And what I would rig up all the, not all the SNCC cars, and numerous SNCC cars is I would run a wire to the tail lights and put a switch under the dashboard.
So if you were driving at night and you were being followed, you could turn off your tail lights.
That's Andy.
You know, there was little things you did you didn't learn to do so I could.
Because I'd worked on cars when I was young.
Do you remember the impetus for the Deacon's coming to town?
I don't know that, well, they wanted to help.
And they believed that fighting back was a solution, which was not a SNCC authorized solution.
And they had, but the meetings were held right where I lived.
So it was a little hard not to be part of it.
And was that the Meredith March?
When they were, the Meredith March was in June 66 from Memphis to Jackson.
And I know the Deacons were protection for that March.
No, it was a group of about six guys, five or six guys.
Very easily guys who wouldn't want to push the wrong way.
And they just came and talked to local folks.
And we had half dozen meetings with people coming to talk to them.
And, you know, I'm not sure they, I didn't host to me.
I mean, SNCC can't do that, but, you know, stuff happens.
Well, I mean, I know that there was, I know quite a bit of discussion and quite a bit of non-discussion
about the issue of non-violence and what it meant for SNCC people and how that shifted over time.
Yeah, well, I think everyone, and I was part of a number of those discussions,
everyone agreed that we would be non-violent, but whether it was a tactic or we believed in it morally,
there was some real difference of opinion.
And as far as I know, it was simply agreed up until the time I left.
And of course, things started to change and started more afrocentric concerns.
That, you know, why you did it wasn't important as long as you were officially non-violent.
Yeah.
And then with those two schools of thought.
But was there a conversation?
Were you part of any conversation with local people about that?
Oh, sure.
Yeah, I was part of, you know, people would say, we ought to just go get our guns.
And I'd say, well, in general, I don't think that's going to work.
Because it wouldn't have.
And we didn't have any manipulation of the levers of power.
So any armaments that people had were small hunting rifles or shotguns.
The one incident I was telling you about with Deputy Weeks was very isolated.
He was out there by himself.
And so there was nobody around to watch his house.
And that one incident.
And he was really a son of a bitch.
I mean, he was, he would do things that most of the police force would never do.
So he probably didn't have a lot of backing either because it looked bad.
What kind of things did he do?
He'd just walk up and smack people and just walk down the street if he thought they weren't, you know,
he'd, you know, walk up to young people and even old people.
And push them and slap them around.
I'm just with no provocation whatsoever.
You know, there were cameras on when he put a shotgun and was a demonstration.
We were about photo rights and he put a shotgun in my chest.
And that was caught on tape somewhere and he got some feedback about that.
And he's a ball of her county deputy?
Yeah.
Cleveland.
Maybe Cleveland City.
Also like a city police officer?
City police officer.
I don't think I understood which, we once stopped and we had to start it.
Maybe they were all county.
Generally in Mississippi, there were city police and county sheriff and deputies.
So he would have been county because he was a deputy.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
He must have been county.
Though at a certain point Mississippi started having all these auxiliary police.
And a lot of times they were the ones that were most out of control.
He'd been known, people knew him for years.
So I think, yeah, he was, he was, he was, he was, had been there for a while.
I mean, he was, people talked about him from the first day I got there.
Yeah.
But he was, he was, you know, one of the biggest problems.
Do you remember the Meredith March?
This is the March where, which is most infamous for Carmichael, introducing the phrase black
power to a national audience, really.
In Greenwood, he uses the phrase black power to capture June 66.
No, I don't.
It's a matter of fact.
And it's interesting, like I said, we didn't get news.
So with it made national headlines, I didn't find out about, went to the North.
Yeah.
Well, it's interesting because James Meredith starts this isolated March.
He's going to go by himself.
He called it the March against fear and then he shot second day out.
Yeah.
And so then civil rights organizations go to matches to pick this up.
But SNCC made it a kind of, um, organized, a voter registration organizing campaign.
Because this is after the passage of the Voting Rights Act.
And so they tried to, everywhere they went, tap into their SNCC, um, contacts and networks and use it to register voters.
So that's why I thought it might have been not just through the national news, but through the...
Uh, it, it, if I was involved, I, I don't remember it.
The biggest demonstration, we didn't do many big things, was when we went down to Jackson,
and I don't know what year that was, maybe 64 or 60, yeah, maybe 64.
And they arrested everybody.
At the fair and took them to the fairgrounds?
Yeah, I was in the fairgrounds.
I think that was 65.
65?
That was the, the biggest event in Mississippi I was at.
I think it tells us.
And we were, you know, they locked us in the fairgrounds.
They had some sort of, I guess I remember being two petitions occasion.
You see the door open.
We could see that the women were locked in another one.
All the men were locked in, in our side.
And I started out in solitary confinement, then they let me out into the general population.
Were you in solitary because you identified as one of the organizers?
I believe so, yeah.
Because I brought up being grouped down.
And then I don't know why they let me out.
You mean you never knew anything.
Funny story about that.
And they, a lot of times they had the door open so you could see was a big double door.
You could see the women.
And of course, a bunch of guys, I wasn't watching the guys, I was watching the women.
You know, and this cop was trying to get this woman to move big women.
And she was sitting down and he hit her one time with his billy club.
And she just covered her head.
And then he went to pick her up and he had, she must have weighed 250 pounds.
He had her halfway up and she need him in the groin.
And you could hear him scream all the way through the walls.
I'm sure then they shut the door and I'm sure they beat the shit out of her.
But you know.
I've interviewed a few men who have said that one of the things that they found most difficult about nonviolence was not protecting, not moving to defend women and children.
Yes.
And given their upbringing and their socialization.
Was that an issue for you?
Well, more than a few times when we had demonstrations, you know, and then we'd have demonstrations where we'd go to various times.
They'd start swinging the clubs at everybody and I would just get, I mean, I guess I knew there was nothing we could do.
I would just lay over people and protect them, let them hit me.
Even though I thought when I was younger, I guess you didn't occur to me that that was an option.
Because I think if you'd really thought back, unless you did something, you know, plan, some sort of plan counter attack, you just get beaten up and thrown in jail.
And as it was, I actually saw my arrest record one time many years later and it was about this thick.
The worst jail I was in, I don't know why I was in that jail.
Worst jail I was in, I don't even remember where it was.
But they would put us, you know, there was white cells, of course, in the blacks.
The black cell was one cell, one big cell.
It had a sink and a toilet and mattresses and it all sloped.
It was a slope so there was a drain in the center and the toilet was overflowing and the mattresses were near the center.
So basically they were soaked in urine and feces.
And so you slept on the floor uphill.
That wasn't a nice place, I recall.
That was probably the worst jail I was in.
Yeah, much more in a few jails.
Sometimes if there were more of us, we'd do things, you know, like, I remember I used, because I carve and stuff.
And I remember making, taking a Styrofoam cups and making a chest set.
Because we could smoke and we'd get cigarettes and I melted a chest set and we had, on the bars and we had this vertical chest set.
Yeah.
And you'd make a chest.
And I was really putting effort into getting these beautiful chest pieces, the ponds, the queen.
You know, you know, what you're going to do when you're in jail.
Yeah, plenty of time to work at it, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't remember.
You just went to jail, it was something that happened, you know.
You know, you talked about, you had no idea about Mississippi, you know.
So what was it like to then spend, you know, four years there?
I mean, how did you adapt or what did Mississippi mean to you after you'd been there a while?
I was working, I mean, I believed in changing the system.
And it was an effort to do that.
In retrospect, I wish I had more insight into what I was, you know, some of the decisions I made and what the effect would be, long term and short term for the people I was working for.
But I accepted the role of being a minion, I guess, and knowing I was doing something I believed in.
I thought it was part of what life's about, I don't know.
It really wasn't very philosophical about it.
It was something you did, and you had to do.
And often when I was in California, I would, you know, go work with C-Farm workers again and talk to them and give them, tell them some things we were doing and we share information.
I know by the lights.
You want to put them on?
Well, no.
I'll tell you if it's...
Okay. I can't see anybody, you know.
Well, there's a world out here.
I'm getting hits on them. I think it would be really difficult for people.
All right.
I'll be in a blurred world.
I'll get the lights up and higher.
It's okay.
Next break, I'll get some more to drink too.
Do you want to do that now?
No, it's okay.
I think by the late 60s, SNCC has people working with the Farm Labor Union, not the Farm Labor, but the Farm Workers in California as well.
Right. Do you know anything about that?
Is there actually a couple of SNCC people out in California?
Well, we're on SNCC staff.
Yeah.
And were they...no, I don't.
Okay.
It's interesting that since the reunion, I have...
There was a Latina who was doing...
She was doing some, you know, Latinos from Latinas who were involved in SNCC.
There weren't many of us, and I didn't know any at the time.
But I've now found some others.
But do you know if they were black, white, or Anglo, or...?
I think that they were black and white.
But I wouldn't...
But I don't know a lot of detail, so I don't want to...
And a number of her elements and connections.
Yeah, she wasn't the one.
But she's not who I'm thinking of with this particular piece.
I ask, you know, to a certain extent, Farm Workers was segmented,
which strike they were working?
There was a strawberry strike, there was a tomato strike, and of course it was a grape strike,
which was the one with a big boycott.
And there were a lot of efforts in different areas,
Delano Valley and San Joaquin Valley and stuff like that.
I'm not going to be able to pull it up.
I've read some work on it by a historian, and so she was piecing together the interconnections.
But I don't have enough detail to be able to say with any...
Yeah, I don't know there was any formal interconnection,
while I was involved.
And when occasionally I go back, communication, we didn't have cell phones.
Yeah.
We didn't have the internet, how things have changed so much.
So getting word back was, you know, when you talk to somebody on the phone,
phone calls back, then we're expensive.
That's why we use the watch line.
I tell kids today, you know,
we used to make calls only at night,
and then we made use to just make sure we talked to, you know,
when somebody had it, we'd call person to person,
and then after they said, no, you know, they'd get the person
and so you could call then station to station,
that you couldn't afford communication.
And now things are so much different, you know,
between unlimited phone calls and the internet, you'd know,
but back then, once you left a place, you were isolated.
It was very difficult for me to find out what was happening in Mississippi after I left.
I wanted to ask about, you know, sort of how you came to leave,
but before I do, there are a couple of documents that we dug up on the Mississippi Freedom Labor Union.
Okay, and for that, I've got to put on my glasses,
because all this looks like this is...
Oh boy!
I think I did this, or so, I remember this is going...
Yes, my goodness, I'd love to get a copy of this.
You can keep that.
I think I typed this.
That's the Chorca.
Yeah, I wondered.
That's for me.
I didn't do this one.
No, because I would never put that square...
I didn't know.
I still have snake pins, by the way, with that little...
Oh, do you?
People have tried to get them.
No, you can't have them.
I also have the Mississippi Freedom Labor Union button,
which I think...
Yeah, I don't know what that looks like.
And show it to you.
I'd love to see it.
It's upstairs.
It's a black and white hand,
and then there's a lantern being held in front of it.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, I did this first one.
So, can you...
We can maybe get a picture of that
so people know what you're talking about, but can you tell us about that?
Okay, I'll see anything else.
I'm a mere graphed, long of the spirit of the project.
No, I don't remember seeing this one.
Oh, my goodness.
My goodness, got it.
Flashback to the path for this page.
City workshops.
I don't remember this.
I'd like to read it, but of course, not going to do it right now.
And this is the...
You said, hold it for a second.
Okay.
Okay, thanks.
Good.
So, can you tell us about how you came to type that up
and who I was involved in?
Because I could tie it together.
I could type.
And they let you in the field.
What did we have?
We had this little portable typewriter.
It was like a royal...
little, you know, the little keys, and it's smack it, and they sound terrible.
And also, there were people who had the churches had typewriters.
There were people with typewriters.
And no such thing as a computer back then.
This came out of meetings.
And kind of work I do, yeah.
My phone.
How much I could pay, yeah.
You know, we took notes and Lee ran the meeting.
And I think...
I don't even know which meeting this was, though.
Mostly, Reverend Jackson was in most of those.
Miss Ruffin would come a lot of times.
Fannie Lou had lots of stuff.
So she wasn't at all a lot of meetings.
There was another minister who...
And I don't know when we did this.
I mean, this wasn't such a big deal that it...
that it sticks in my memory.
But I remember typing it.
And I don't...
How did we copy?
How do we copy?
We didn't have photocopies, though.
We had Memeograph and we had stencils.
Dict...
Dictograph.
Dicta...
Okay.
Memeograph.
Yeah, it was special from...
But then there was a Dicta thing.
I forgot.
But that looks like the kind where you cut the stencil.
Yeah.
But they both...
Memeograph is one type and there was another copying thing.
Dicta something or other.
Did the Atlanta print shop ever do anything for you?
Not.
There were no black print shops and no white print shop.
But we didn't have the money to do that sort of thing.
We could have asked...
For some of the flyers we had sometimes,
we would tell people up north that we wanted.
If somebody was coming down,
you'd say, can you do this and we get a...
You know, I'm just copies of that way.
I know the SNCC office in Atlanta at a certain point had a print shop.
Yeah, they had a print shop.
I know they had a copier.
Now they had a print shop actually.
Wilson...
Brown?
That's right.
I know somebody who was line a type.
Who used to do line a type.
I remember talking to somebody who had that.
And I was jealous or something.
I said, you know, that's stuff.
Because we didn't have any of that.
I know at a certain point, Verella was making films.
The people coming through doing things.
A lot of the churches had...
It's not Memeograph is another...
And that's what I think this has done.
That's why the copy is so poor.
Dictigraph.
Dictus something or other.
Anyway, it's much easier to cut this stencil in.
Memeograph, if you make a mistake, you had to cut it off with a razor blade.
And this one...
This was a blue paper.
And you put them...
Again, the master in and crank it along.
Yeah.
I worked...
Boy, those, yeah.
So it was something like that.
Would you carry that around then to people and use it as a way to...
No, actually, I think we would do this in churches after a speech.
We'd have all the rabble rise in this singing.
And people would make presentations.
And we'd have either...
I don't know if we used clip-flords or we had a table, but churches have all that.
And we'd tell people to come to the back.
And I would have people...
I'd be one of the folks signing folks up.
Helping them fill this in.
A lot of people couldn't be the right.
And so we'd be filling it in for them.
And I think I even carried this to bars sometimes.
I believe I did.
Yeah.
Because that was one of my venues.
Which meant since I got up at sunrise and I didn't do a lot of sleeping.
Lest it kept you busy.
Yeah.
Were there things that were hard about being in Mississippi
or things that also you found particularly rewarding?
Well, the whole thing was rewarding.
I mean, in its total.
And we had fun, too.
I've told people that...
I mean, I know it must have been one of the most horrible things in the world to be in a concentration camp.
But I'm sure people found moments of enjoyment.
I mean, certainly we had relations.
I'm talking about intimate relations.
And we danced and we laughed and got our ass beat up.
But there were plenty of good times.
It wasn't just all serious.
There was a lot of good times.
And the songs got people pumped up really good.
I mean, people sang songs in jail.
They sang songs in the field.
They sang songs in churches.
Were you ever a song leader?
Oh, everybody laughed.
I mean, I still...
We are soldiers in the Army.
We have to fight.
Perhaps we have to die.
We have to hold up.
The blood stained banner.
Have to hold it up until we die.
I was the bass.
Yeah.
And they went on forever.
And the freedom singers used to come by.
They tore all us out.
And they were wonderful.
Yeah.
So, are there...
You mentioned Lee Bankhead and a few other people.
Are there other people that you spend a lot of time working with that you can tell us about?
I can't say any name.
And I've tried to call his name.
I lost it about 10 years ago maybe.
Fenway Ham is nephew and I used to do a lot together.
We used to, as a matter of fact, he...
You know, I was the ones who were in Delta Plines plantation.
We went to Yazoo City together and got our asses right out of there.
Can you tell us about those two Delta Plines and Yazes?
Well, I wish I could tell you his name.
But it seems not to be there.
I remember after Delta Plines won...
He...
Okay, Delta Plines, we went there.
Oh, yeah, because there's a couple of good stories.
Delta Plines was a plantation.
The old-fashioned plantation that had cabins that people lived in, sharecroppers.
They basically were.
Although, sharecroppers, not supposed to exist.
And we were doing voter registration.
We couldn't have done union organizing.
We had...
It wasn't...
That's the sort of place we could have done that.
We could have done it, you briefly, before the interview about it.
That's where we met some older people down by the river
who were living in these...
These shacks.
And they were talking about...
Oh, we were the same group that had come to organize to get people registered to vote before.
Nobody's been here before.
This is SNCC with everyone.
With everyone's stupid enough or tough enough or whatever to go in there.
And I talked to them and I talked to them about when it was...
I thought it was in the 40s or the 30s.
I mean, they didn't know when they were old enough and of course they were old then.
And that...
The Communist Party had...
Because when I said the word Communist, I knew enough of politics since I was reading.
And it...
No, I didn't know it was Communist Party then.
I know they'd come in and float boats.
I actually researched it later after I got out of the South.
In fact, there was CP, Communist Party, who had come down to Mississippi
to register people to vote.
And then they came down to the river and would stop it where they saw houses.
But so I realized then that we weren't the first.
I mean, the 60s wasn't the beginning of it.
So were they more receptive because they had this memory of earlier people?
Well, they seemed receptive.
But these particular people were simply felt they were too old.
And how would they get out there?
They didn't have any transportation.
You had to go to whatever town was close and I'd have to look on the map I've forgotten.
But they hadn't had transportation so they couldn't basically get off the plantation.
I mean, there was no way.
Somewhere along the line somebody dropped a dime on somebody called.
And so there were these people driving up and down in trucks looking for us.
And we left our car.
We'd walked in and left our car.
We wouldn't be seen.
And so we were hiding out for several days.
And I almost said his name.
I remember when we got back, his hair was so nice.
He couldn't get a brush or comb through it.
And he had to shave his head.
He had to get it because he had something with a short afro.
Poor guy.
And mine was pretty funky too.
We hadn't washed and done anything.
We'd been eating uncooked greens and stuff like that for three days.
Hiding in ditches and ditches are not fun to hide in.
We went to Yazoo City.
I don't know how they, I guess they knew the car.
And the cops had lists of SNCC cars.
And that was always a problem.
And the cops just met us and said, you know, if you don't turn around and leave,
then you're going straight to jail.
We'll keep you in jail for several months.
And we said, okay, we'll turn around and leave and we'll have to do it.
I know Mrs. Hammerhead, many brothers and sisters.
So I imagine she had quite a few nephews.
But is there anything you can tell us about that we might help us track down his name
if we can try to look into it?
No.
I don't even know his father's name.
I mean, I probably did.
I mean, I knew his family and I knew every, I knew, I mean, if I can't remember him,
and he used to stay in the office with me.
And I wondered because I thought maybe, trying to find out if he's still alive
and to reach out.
And I didn't think about him for a long time.
You know, it was just part of memories.
I guess it was hard for me to leave.
Once I left, you know, part of me wanted to go back.
And part of me wanted to keep in touch and see people.
He couldn't make phone calls, I said, you know.
And a lot of people didn't even have phones.
And, you know, cell phones were so much, you know,
it changed the world as, as email.
And people didn't write much.
I mean, not many people wrote things.
So, uh, Dictograph.
That's the word.
Dictograph.
What, um, why, why, how did you come to leave?
I figured it was time.
There were a lot of, uh, a lot of groups coming in.
Uh, uh, uh, Delta Ministries was in doing a lot of work.
There were a lot of groups where a lot of, uh,
we got a lot of volunteers about the time I left.
And, um, I was up north doing fundraising.
And I started to go down when I got, when I go back, I said,
you know, I'm not sure.
And I talked to people and they were doing also stuff.
And I didn't think I was, you know, key anymore.
I didn't think I was needed that much.
And a lot, a lot of volunteers.
And I said, it's time to move on.
And I also bumped into, I was in DC.
And they were, uh, because I, I'd done short order cooking and, you know,
done all that to myself through college.
And they were starting a union.
I mean, not there was a one starting them.
The, uh, Cook's hotels and restaurant workers union was doing a big,
uh, they were striking all over the city.
And, um, I happened to be talking to them.
They said, well, you know, love to have your work for us.
I mean, they paid, they paid a real salary, by the way.
And, you know, and, you know, I said, you know, and, um,
so I, I stayed.
And then, then I thought after the strike, we, we did pretty well.
We won some places, some places went non-union.
And I thought of going back.
And of course, by that time there was a lot of, uh, pan-African stuff.
And, and, and some of that already had changed.
And I thought that was good.
I mean, I, I thought the pan-Africanism was good.
And, um, and that it needed to be more of all the black movement.
Mm-hmm.
And so you decided to stay in DC, DC area then?
I stayed in DC.
I, then I started traveling.
I went, I decided it was time to go to Mexico.
I spent a lot of time in Mexico and I traveled around Mexico.
And, um, did a lot of things with traditional native religion.
Um, got really interested.
I can, I can marry you in DC and California.
I mean, I'm a priest.
How is that?
Um, and I got really into some native cultural stuff.
And I traveled other countries and, and Central South America.
And, um, traveled on the States.
I hadn't seen this.
I'd, I'd, I'd, traveled some of the States.
But I got, you know, but I'm around the States and worked, where I went.
And I worked in Foundaries in Minneapolis and, and, and, ranches and Arizona.
And, you know, just, for a while, just was trying to figure out and always doing political stuff.
Mm-hmm.
How do you think the, I mean, I know you've been an organizer and an activist.
It seems your entire adult life.
How do you think that work in the, the sort of black freedom movement and in Mississippi?
Influence that?
Talked me.
Yeah.
Um, it taught me, uh, how to organize with people who I may not have had something in common with, to start with.
Do we all have things in common, of course?
And I guess I focused on that.
It broadened my horizons and ways I never could have imagined when I went down.
I don't know, that make me, and you know, I guess I was always, I would never really good with fear.
I mean, I don't have good sense about what I'm supposed to be afraid.
I always had that problem.
You know, I went with fire workers and they were beating us.
For a long time, I was an iron worker doing towers and bridges and people who say, doesn't bother you.
Most of them happen as you follow.
The ground will stop you.
Indeed.
It is the fall that hurts us as a sudden stop.
Um, and so I guess it, I don't know if it taught me to have gumption to do what I think is right or maybe I already had that, but it certainly cemented it.
So, you know, if I really think this is the right thing to do, I'm a little bit of a bulldog.
Yeah.
What was it like to go back and work on SB's campaign?
It was really a trip.
Um, and we took, well, we took a van full of volunteers down.
None of them, some of them had been to the South some, but none had been to Mississippi, that part.
And I mean, I even, as I said, drove by, saw the shack.
I said, I lived in that.
I mean, this isn't big enough for my dog to live with you.
Um, it was, I mean, the South had changed, but hadn't changed.
I mean, many things in, in, uh, in jacks, well, I wasn't in Jackson that much, because he was running in basically the same areas I worked in, which I think was a third congressional fourth.
It might have, well, you know, it changed a number of times, but it was the Delta District.
Yeah.
It might have been the second congressional district.
That's the rings of Delta.
Yeah.
Anyway, uh, so it was the same area.
And in Cleveland, there was an amazing, I think it was a, the sheriff was black or something, an amazing amount of changes in those in that time.
Once you got out in the rural areas, uh, because I tried to go to rural areas and go to these houses where, you know, no, no sidewalks,
the ditch runs down in front of the house and, you know, there's a little bridge across it and it's up on these little concrete stills.
That's what all of the black neighborhood in Jackson and, and Cleveland was like when I was there.
You could tell when I was in Cleveland, and in most of the South, what was black and what was white, because streets were paved and they had underground sewers and in the black area they didn't.
Um, it, there were a lot of teachers making good money and the schools were interested.
Great. So they were making the same money as the white tea or, I don't know, same, but they were making good money.
But then in the rural areas, it wasn't, um, working on those cramp rain was thrilling.
He won, it was 82 votes and I told people in the way back every one of us can say we changed.
We got 82 people to vote. And so every one of us can say if I wasn't there, that wouldn't happen.
And I've used that example many times since then.
Yeah. How did you connect it to his campaign? How did you get connected to his campaign?
Probably to the Democratic Party. Yeah. You know, I've worked with the Democratic Party and they put out a call. They needed help.
Yeah. And we organized, um, we had, we, yeah, because the Democratic Party, I think, rented the van.
We had one of those stretch vans. I think we seats 12 and probably had 11 or 12 people in it. We had jammed.
Yeah. Yeah. Must have been a nice feeling to have them win.
Oh, yeah. It was incredible.
I remember I've heard stories that when Amsy Moore and Bob Moses first started talking about voter registration and political work,
which led to SNCC's campaign in Mississippi, they were talking about having a representative from the Delta in doubt.
And Mike Espio was the first. Yeah. Yeah. Was it a full circle?
So where are some of the highlights or things that you think are particularly important that you've done since then?
I, as you say, it's a, it's a long, long list.
Okay. So what is this button?
That's, um, one of the official buttons put out by the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party.
And, um, I may have one of the only left around in the country.
People have tried to get it many times. I've got a number of buttons from back then. Core buttons and SNCC buttons and,
um, and things like that.
No, one SNCC, and finds out about them, they'll be knocking on your door.
I'm actually wondered what to do with it. There are a number of libraries.
I've given them, probably going to give them to my daughter, um, who gets all sorts of stuff.
Actually, I made for her birthday one time.
Fortunately, we didn't have T-shirts back then. Yeah.
But I made her a T-shirt from things I've done since then, with political events and marches on Washington and stuff like that.
I made, I took them all, made her quilt.
Wow.
So they're also together and I showed up this quilt. So she has this quilt that, part of my political history.
It's too bad she has it. Otherwise we could take a look at it.
I probably have some pictures of it, but I'd have to find them. They're digital. So I could probably dig them out.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So.
Oh, I'm sorry. I can't. So so long for me seeing anymore.
I don't know.
That's okay.
Occasionally I'm downstairs. I've been wearing glasses for many, many years, but occasionally I come downstairs and wake up and I'm like,
good to have a upstairs. I said, wait a minute.
I can't see anything what's going on.
How did I do that?
Yeah.
So can you talk about Ms. Hamer in a mass meeting?
I thought we did that. She was, she was a very powerful speaker, really powerful speaker.
And she dominated the room.
And I think everyone, I mean, people have seen her and there are lots of movies I've seen her, you know, keep on keeping on and stuff like that.
More I think impressive was how she dominated meetings. And she was in a number of meetings with all of the major,
major, snake people that you hear about. And nobody ever went against her. They tried to, but it didn't work.
And I've been told a number of times is what they simply do is say, well, we're just not going to disagree whether we're just going to go do our thing because you couldn't.
She was a very powerful person.
Can you remember any examples of what some of the differences might have been?
Oh, no, not. I don't.
Oh, I'm trying to dig up some old memories. They were political, whether we have a demonstration or which town we would be should focus on to try and do voter registration.
Most of it wasn't union stuff.
And some of it was, I guess, tactical for the Democratic Party, the Freedom Democratic Party.
Whether we, I think at one time, we were trying to run a candidate and whether it was going to eat.
And we could use that for just somebody who it was registered because not many people registered at that time.
I don't remember who that was. I got a big picture of him in my mind, but it was a male.
And somebody was going to try and run and I remember whether it was a waste of our effort to try and do that was symbolic, but it was important enough to do.
And to be honest, I don't remember which side she was on.
I don't think we did it, which means probably she wasn't supportive of it.
I mean, I do know that there were a number of symbolic, largely symbolic candidates early on.
And I guess you would have been leaving Mississippi right about the time that the first elections took place where there were significant black voters after the Voting Rights Act.
Yeah. I mean, but we used to do so many things to those are the details about.
You know, they had some places they wanted you to tell them the beans were in the jar and some places they had to interpret the Constitution.
And we, you know, go over the Constitution line by line, hour by hour, and very few people would they accept.
A couple they did. We had, you know, a handful here in their register.
Do you, do you remember or have a sense of what the impact was like on the ground in Mississippi after the Voting Rights Act passed, how that changed your work or it changed if you weren't working on voter registration, then how it changed the context for that?
When I left, it still was hard to register voters.
The FBI was mostly Southern crackers.
And I mean, you know, when the FBI would come after, you know, there was a beating or something like that interview you, you know that it was going to happen.
It wasn't so mostly they upheld the system. So we didn't, we had not seen any change by the time I left.
And I guess one of the things I regretted, by the way, was staying and seeing some of that come to fruition.
But a lot, as I said, a lot of people were coming down and there were a lot of people, there was enough money that people were making salaries and holding events that were funded.
And it was hard to compete.
So who do you know who these folks are or what the mechanism for?
Well, Delta Ministry said a number down.
Delta Ministry said a number down. And there was some other groups too.
Yeah, yeah. Well, and I know, and this has been different part of the state, but I know that once, you know, in a little bit later, there's once Charles Evers uses FAAD, establishes FAAD as his base.
There's a lot of interest in some of his political campaigns. So I know that the campaigns were drawing outside attention.
Yeah, they were, and money and people, which is a good thing. I mean, things changed.
A lot of, I think, you know, I don't want a bad mouth any other organizations.
Yeah. It's not something I wanted to.
You mentioned the poverty programs or Head Start.
Did you work closely or collaboratively with any of them?
I'm sure. I mean, everybody did everything.
Yeah. Yeah. And that's the whole thing.
I even taught, you know, math and some of them, but getting funding, getting a building, doing all that organizing, it was giving the kids a Head Start.
And I think everybody believed in it. Everybody worked on it.
It was just one of the many things that people did.
We were 24 hours a day, seven days a week.
We were available bodies while most people had to work or had a bunch of kids they had to take care of.
So a lot of the stuff that needed to get done, you know, we could help get done.
I was a reasonable carpenter. So, you know, I remember we were fixing some building up and, you know, putting up partitions and stuff like that.
So everybody just pitched in, did what they good.
Yeah. So what are some of the, I think I just asked this and then we took the break.
But do you want to pick out some of the things that you've worked on and some of the many things you've worked on?
Well, I have a per chance for working on failed causes, I guess.
I might work on Jesse Jackson's two campaigns, for instance.
I designed a way of building ferrocement fishing boats after the Revolution in Grenada.
I was very involved in Grenada.
And it was a wonderful, wonderful place.
They had a true bottom up government.
They had local community that would feed into regional communities that feed up.
So the government they established was that way.
They abolished, for instance, prostitution.
They didn't do it by abolishing prostitution.
But I said, anybody who's in the trade, you want a job, we will find you something to do.
There was nobody left.
How did you get involved in that?
I don't know.
I heard about it.
Of course, you know, I've been to Cuba and I heard about it and I said I'd go there and I was really impressed.
And I talked a lot.
I worked in the fishing villages for a little bit because I'd lived.
I'd already lived in the Caribbean when I went there.
I lived in Trinidad for a while, just went to Trinidad and Barbados and, you know, Dominican and places.
Haiti.
And so I'd already been to the Caribbean because I traveled.
And so I had a way of building ferro-summit fishing boats and we were going to be building.
The government was going to be building.
I was the director of the project and of course the US invaded.
I just like to work on campaigns that don't work or issues that don't work.
I was his national coordinator of states.
I was in Fume.
I was his, as I said, county coordinator and he didn't win either.
We lost five.
Well, three percentage points and they had almost ten times as much money as we did.
The Democratic support to candidate.
One of those.
One of those moral victories, right?
Yeah, no.
More victories.
Anyway, so I worked on all things like immigration issues and Palestinian issues.
We did win too.
We won the immigration and the Dream Act in Maryland and of course, gay marriage in Maryland.
So I've had some but most of them, you know, and I do a lot of work with elected officials.
And I think I've done a lot of things in the community over the years supported issues of empowerment in the community that have been successful.
I think that people coming out of the movement have different and changing and complex thinking about the relationship between organizing work and traditional politics.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know if traditional politics is the right word.
But working through the political process and how effective that can be, you seem to have done both.
Yeah, I do both.
And I've been in certainly those discussions numerous times.
The biggest or one of a good example, I think of that that I've mentioned many times is I did a lot work with the zapatistas and Chepis.
And you know about that.
Do you want to just give a little bit of an introduction?
Oh, okay. For people who don't know, there is a lot of discrimination in Mexico against native people and it's usually run by people, misty toe or angles who run the government.
And the zapatistas are mostly mine and several other tribal groups in the Chappas Park, which is a southern, south, eastern tip.
We're not quite all the way down to the Yucatan of Mexico.
And they basically said there were a lot of land that was owned by non-resident landowners who lived in Mexico City and they just took it over.
They said this is native land and they set up a government.
And there was a lot of back and forth and especially the landowners would hire paramilitary police.
And I went down to document several massacres and there were a lot of people who men and women and children killed.
So it is a struggle that still goes on and they have what appears to be an independent land.
But it's not totally independent.
But they are making sure that the profits go to the people and I can give you lots of examples in Mexico.
I was an El Salvador where the coffee pickers don't drink coffee because they can't afford it and they'll be attired if they take a coffee bean home.
So they pick and coffee all day long but can't even drink coffee.
Okay, getting back to we had and I was with a support group in the States because we can do more to help them some money and trying influence.
And there was a situation going on with the federal police going in and doing a lot of mayhem.
And we were you know crying and screaming about it all the political lefties I was with.
And then we finally got to a friend friend of mine and somebody else's got to Kennedy.
So the Kennedy when he was alive and his aide made a phone call and stopped it.
Now that happened because people worked on those political campaigns.
In Kennedy's case actually was a good enough guy.
I have lots of elected officials that I can call up and say we need to look at this.
We need to do something about it.
They don't do it just because you're a nice guy or a nice woman.
They do it because you can turn votes out and you will turn votes out.
I'm a threat to you. You have to be able to say I will turn votes out and kick your butt out of office unless you get right.
And the same thing for a lot of these issues.
As I said we had got marriage equality and the Dream Act passed in Maryland because we did the grunt work of going out to the people and having them go back to the politicians.
So it's both.
I don't think you can do just one.
I mean I'm as far out of the left as you can get but that you have to work within the system too.
I remember what was it that used to say that revolution will not be televised.
It's not televised and it didn't take place and you know and it's not going to in this country because they have.
Someone's a strong enough leader that usually buy the mountains one way or another or assassinate if they do that too.
What are the things that you're most interested in today?
The Supreme Court decision of you know they just encased so everybody knows they just overturned part of the voting rights act and unfortunately there's no way you can affect the Supreme Court by doing political work.
They seem to be in there for life.
They did some decent things about K rights but only because I think they had no choice on that one.
I'm interested whatever's happening. I'm always interested in the struggle, the Palestinian struggle and the struggles of people all over the world not just in the States anymore.
I used to be when I was in the South I didn't look beyond the US and now I'm going to the US with all the problems all over.
Was that that isolation that you talked about in the South or is that part of your own sort of growth and travel?
Certainly the isolation. I remember who was it that came from Africa?
There was a song. It was a so-
O'Gingho, Dingo.
Yes. And I mean Africa was then to me was just like this far place and I knew nothing about it.
I knew Mexico and I knew down probably...
I don't think I'd been South of Mexico in that part then.
But you know all that far stuff and you knew about of course European history, everybody read that in school but there was no African history, no Central South American history, no Caribbean history.
And it wasn't until I got...
The South you certainly wouldn't learn about it except for that one time. I mean Africa was never mentioned in the news.
And yeah it was personal growth.
Were you part of conversations in SNCC about Africa and the international context?
Some of them yes and I would put them in context of you know Native people...well actually it was probably more Latinos at the time.
I wasn't that focused on the Native issues.
Yeah I would say and you know there's a tie and I certainly appreciated people going back to their roots and it actually probably is.
And it also affected a lot of other people. A lot of Latinos started to look at what that means.
It wasn't just the Brown-Barrés that were doing it but the Larassa.
And I was one of the original members of Larassa.
Can you talk about that?
I was a distant member. I mean I...when I was in California I was...but that's time I was in the East Coast.
And probably along with it, Kristi Rodriguez who was my place sister.
And she was...I know the people involved in it but I was just...you know...
We by that time we had...phones were working. We did a lot of correspondence. Elect...
No we didn't have the internet that when it started. Got my brain.
You know it's hard to remember how you communicated. So we got...we'd write letters.
Oh yeah I remember. Historians like that letter writing era.
Yeah well if you could find the letters. I mean I...I actually...I've got boxes and boxes of that stuff.
Up in the attic. Boy I'd give that away too.
Is this personal correspondence and organizational papers?
No correspondence with political organizations. I mean I was involved in so many political organizations.
Yeah and I've actually found...I don't know...I've tried to give...do I...no I gave that away.
I had some old SNCC stuff that was official comments and correspondence in the...
But I gave it to one of the libraries. Yeah.
Yeah I could. But it's all hard copy. I don't need...I need electronics so I can sort through it.
Yeah.
I don't know. I mean I do so many political things now as I said in the biography.
I was sitting there and I could...I could copy. I could put on my glasses except I can't...you don't like me to do that.
And look at some of them and I know I'm missing a whole lot of them.
Worked on just numbers of political campaigns that worked in the Statehood Party when I got to DC.
Because that seemed like a reasonable thing to do.
Were there a lot of movement people involved in the Statehood?
Yeah. We were local movement people.
Local movement people.
But I mean there were Julius Hobson was known for a lot of stuff. He was one of the key people.
Josephine Butler was also part of the US Soviet Union Friendship Society.
And...she passed away. There were three major people.
Hilda Mason, who was well known as...I mean you probably crossed her name.
She black and her husband was a lawyer and he was white.
But she was doing a lot of civil rights stuff in the South and in the North.
And those were three of the key people. They were all lefties.
What are some of...are there other things that you'd like to talk about?
Well I don't know that this is a forum to plead for change.
But that's what I'm always worried about. It's empowerment of people.
So that people get to make decisions for themselves.
And I mean I note for instance that especially in the immigration as people...
And people are saying, people shouldn't be able to come to this country.
First of all I've got a nice sign over there. We don't recognize the borders.
The borders are artificial and I don't know who invited the pilgrims here anyway.
You want to talk about immigration issues. They weren't invited.
The fact that it was even an article in the Washington Post editorial bio-etheno.
And I think they're going to publish letter to the other railroad.
And he was saying about, okay now we've made it because the politicians are paying attention to Latino issues.
Look at the schools. Our kids are just doing terribly.
And black kids aren't doing very well either.
The problems of racism are still alive and well in this country.
And we need to do something about it. I mean the Voting Rights Act is a very small part of it.
But there needs to be some willingness to address it.
People who thought Obama would do something about it, of course we're wrong.
He's trying to, if anything, hide from the issue so he doesn't get thrown back at him.
But there are just serious issues and a lot of them are issues of poverty.
Not just ethnicity. And for one of the richest nations in the world...
And of course it's the 99 percent. Well it's even worse than that.
It's the .01 percent that own just huge amounts of wealth and make decisions for everyone else.
And that's what we really should be addressing.
Are there differences you think? I mean there's obviously the technological differences.
But what kinds of... If you're talking about the organizing you did in Mississippi when you started.
And the organizing needs to be done today. How would you talk to young people today about that and what they might do?
Well actually some young people really get involved. It's nice.
There was a generation when I go to political events.
There was a generation that is younger than I am. But not the kids that are coming out of high school and just getting into college.
There was a time if you go to those meetings. There's this old folks and young folks.
And there was a time when there were these people... There was a generation that weren't involved.
I actually fault us, the older folks who were involved, because we didn't teach our kids to be active.
I mean if we'd have spent so much time ensuring our kids were activists.
I know so many people whose children and would use Jean Wiley because she's mentioned.
She's got a kid, he's not in politics. And these kids were brought up around politics but not...
They weren't given the fire and the bell had to be involved. I think some of that's changing.
In terms of kids are certainly well more informed now than... I mean they know stuff.
Not just about sex but about politics, about international.
You can't find a kid probably in the DC area that doesn't know more about Africa.
When they're 12 then I did when I was 21 or Central America.
I mean so there's information there but there's also a great push to keep people from pushing for change.
And I think that's always been there and sponsored by the large corporations.
The 1% or the 0.01%.
That control the media and help and try and foster decisions on other people.
They've gotten more sophisticated at that.
So it's a different battle and we just have to try and figure out.
Again just fight it one step at a time.
Thank you for the other things that we should touch on.
No I just hope kids continue getting involved.
Do you talk to students, classrooms at all?
I don't talk in classrooms. I talk a lot one on one. I talk... I don't go into classrooms.
I notice that none of the SNCC people at the conference at the 50th anniversary are doing classroom work.
I do some. There have been a couple of events they've asked me to speak at them.
You use larger events. But I don't... you know and it's what it was like.
And I tell them it's not what it was like, it's what it is like.
Yeah I think going into classrooms would help.
I like to think that I try to work on issues that will get attention politically or in the media that will reach more people.
And I certainly credit teachers who are out there day after day.
Well thank you very much. We're talking with us.
This has been a presentation of the library.